Hey everybody, we're here with another exciting interview. Today, we have Abhay, who's a software engineer at Anduril Industries. Go ahead and say hello to us, Abhay, and tell us a little bit about your current role there. Yeah, thanks for having me on the podcast, Jason and Patrick. I'm Abhay. I'm a software engineer at Anduril Industries, and I work on platform infrastructure, mainly focusing on aspects of simulation, deployment, and so forth. Before that, I did a lot of work in our autonomy area of expertise and did some foundational work there, and also have a background in perception and machine learning.
大家好，我们今天又迎来了一次精彩的访谈。今天我们请到了 Abhay，他是 Anduril Industries 的一名软件工程师。Abhay，请先跟大家打个招呼，并简单介绍一下你目前在那里的工作。好的，谢谢 Jason 和 Patrick 邀请我参加播客。我是 Abhay，是 Anduril Industries 的一名软件工程师，我主要负责平台基础设施，重点关注仿真、部署等方面。在此之前，我在我们的自主技术领域做了很多工作，打下了一些基础，此外我在感知和机器学习方面也有一定的背景。
You said so many buzzwords already right up front. You know, a lot of people very excited. I mean, I think there's a couple topics that I think are very motivational to people early on when they're getting into programming, or at least they were for me. Maybe now people are excited by like, you know, websites and web apps and stuff. But for me, it was always building games and building robots. Right? Yeah, I guess to the point of buzzwords, I often like to say we do everything but blockchain at Andreo. So we really do have that diversity of expertise. And certainly robotics is one of the areas that we are particularly excited about.
你一上来就说了这么多专业术语。你知道，很多人对此感到非常兴奋。我的意思是，我认为有几个话题对于刚开始接触编程的人来说非常有激励作用，至少对我来说是这样。也许现在人们对网站、Web 应用之类的东西更感兴趣，但对我来说，一直以来都是构建游戏和机器人。对吧？是的，说到专业术语，我经常说我们在 Anduril 除了区块链什么都做。所以我们确实拥有多样化的专业知识。当然，机器人技术是我们特别感兴趣的领域之一。
I'm particularly excited about. And yeah, I, you know, the first time i started working on robotics was at stanford where we had this fun project of well having this sort of chair bot and okay the sort of problem space was going to study how humans interact with various robotic furniture and how can you sort of imagine those kinds of interactions and sort of worked on building this chair robot that was literally, you know, a chair with a Roomba attached to it. And you could control it using an iPad and try to like run your experiments that way. So yeah, it's a fun space. I mean, my first thought is like you're programming the chair to move out from underneath someone
我特别感兴趣。是的，你知道，我第一次开始从事机器人技术是在斯坦福大学，当时我们有一个很有趣的项目，就是制作这种“椅子机器人”。这个问题的研究空间是研究人类如何与各种机器人家具互动，以及你如何想象这类互动。我参与了制作这个椅子机器人，它实际上就是一把装了 Roomba（扫地机器人）的椅子。你可以用 iPad 控制它，并尝试通过这种方式进行实验。所以，是的，这是一个很有趣的领域。我的第一反应是，你是在把椅子编程，让它在别人试图坐下时从下面移开，把它当作恶作剧。但我猜你当时不是在做这个。
when they try to sit on it as a prank. But I assume that's not what you were doing. Yeah, I cannot deny that never happened. But certainly it is. Yeah, it was a lot around what is an acceptable approach? Like, can you think of a chair? What are the sort of acceptable interactions that would be sort of socially pleasing or, you know, not aggressive necessarily thinking about how robots should interact with humans in general and trying to build like a design model around that was sort of the research goal. And yeah, so at least that was my foray into robotics and certainly have taken it a lot more places from there. Very cool. So for a second here,
是的，我不能否认那从未发生过。但可以肯定的是，这更多是关于什么是可接受的方法。比如，你能想到一把椅子吗？什么样的互动是社会上令人愉悦的，或者说不一定具有攻击性的？思考机器人应该如何与人类互动，并尝试围绕这一点建立一个设计模型，这就是研究目标。所以，至少那是我的机器人技术初探，从那以后我确实在更多地方应用了它。非常酷。那么，稍微停一下，
I think most people kind of know the word robot or even know of robots, right? So you mentioned like Roomba, people think of sort of like androids. So I mean, maybe in like your mind, not necessarily like a definition. I mean, maybe that's kind of too boring. But like, what is it that makes robotics as like a field or a practice? Like what makes it different? What makes it robotics? And then for you, like what makes it something that you're excited to work on? Yeah, yeah. I guess I think of robotics in a pretty broad sense.
我想大多数人都知道“机器人”这个词，甚至了解机器人，对吧？所以你提到了像 Roomba 这样的东西，人们会想到像仿生人那样的东西。所以，也许在你心中，不一定是一个定义——我的意思是，那可能太无聊了——但机器人作为一个领域或实践，是什么让它与众不同？是什么让它成为机器人技术？对你来说，是什么让你对从事这项工作感到兴奋？是的，是的。我想我是在一个相当广泛的意义上思考机器人技术的。
So usually, like you mentioned, people think of Roomba or even more in the broader sense, people think of like some sort of robot, like C3PO or R2D2. And it's like somehow it has a body and a physical state. But robotics can be much broader than that. Really, even just a sensor with a control loop, meaning that it interacts with the environment
所以通常情况下，就像你提到的，人们会想到 Roomba，或者在更广泛的意义上，人们会想到某种机器人，比如 C3PO 或 R2D2。感觉它好像有一个身体和一个物理状态。但机器人技术可以比这广泛得多。实际上，即使只是一个带有控制回路的传感器，意味着它与环境互动，
and gains data from the environment. You could think of that really as a robot. And in that broad sense, robots are all around us. Even your fridge has a robotic component to it. And, you know, even your microwave or certainly your phone. So yeah, that's how I really think about it. And if you think about it in that broad sense, then you can start making a sense of really what are robots and what they do for us and the value of them. Are there things about programming robots like that, that you found in your work that are sort of different or unique to, I mean, I guess for me, like hearing you say that
并从环境中获取数据，你也可以把它看作是一个机器人。在那种广泛的意义上，机器人无处不在。甚至你的冰箱也有机器人组件，还有你的微波炉，当然还有你的手机。所以，是的，这就是我真正看待它的方式。如果你从这个广泛的意义上思考，那么你就可以开始理解什么是机器人，它们为我们做什么，以及它们的价值所在。在你的工作中，有没有发现编程机器人有什么不同或独特之处？我的意思是，对我来说，听到你这么说，
it involves the physical world and sort of interacting with it in some way, measuring it, affecting it, and having some control loop for that. I mean, is that the essence of what makes it sort of different? Or do you think there's something more there? Like before you're mentioning your chair bot and how like there's a human component that once you have something interacting in the world, you're sort of interacting with humans as well. Like what do you find particularly engaging? Or is there something that you find particularly engaging about that? Yeah, I guess there are a few differences. The main thing I would say is that interactive component with the environment. So you can contrast it against like building a database where it's a lot less effectual
它涉及物理世界并以某种方式与之互动、测量它、影响它，并为此拥有某种控制回路。我的意思是，这就是它与众不同的本质吗？还是你认为还有更多东西？就像你之前提到的椅子机器人，以及一旦你有东西在世界上互动，你也在与人类互动。你觉得什么特别吸引人？或者你发现其中有什么特别吸引人的地方吗？是的，我想有几个不同点。我会说最主要的是与环境的互动组件。所以你可以把它与构建数据库进行对比，后者在某种程度上效果较差，
in the sense that you don't necessarily directly interface with the human. You're usually serving requests for other pieces of software. Whereas usually when you're making robots, a sensor or some sort of actuator, it does have that closer control loop or interaction loop with the environment. And that sort of is, I would say quite different, mostly because interacting with the real world is really on a higher dimension almost. So when you're building a, let's say a drone and you have to make it fly around, it's kind of funny in the beginning, at least because when I was first
因为你不一定直接与人类交互。你通常是在为其他软件组件提供请求。而当你制造机器人时，传感器或某种执行器确实与环境有更紧密的控制回路或交互回路。我会说这确实非常不同，主要是因为与现实世界互动几乎是在一个更高的维度上。所以当你制造一架无人机并让它四处飞行时，起初会觉得有点好笑，因为当我第一次
writing control loops, you would think that the robot would behave in a fairly straightforward manner, but it almost never does. And it does take some getting used to in terms of building a robust, robust robotic system and making it, you making it impervious to all the various states that could be possible in a complex environment. Oh, impervious. Oh, I like that. Yeah. I mean, I've done a little bit of hobbyist dabbling. And I think this thing you're pointing out, right, that it's very different from my day-to-day programming to work on something which has mechanical failures, mechanical limits. You know, there's like, you have to think about, it's not just I'm at value
编写控制回路时，你会认为机器人的行为会相当直接，但它几乎从来不是这样。在构建一个稳健的机器人系统，并使其能够抵御复杂环境中可能出现的所有各种状态方面，确实需要一些时间来适应。哦，抵御。哦，我喜欢这个词。是的，我做过一点业余爱好。我认为你指出的这一点，即它与我日常编程工作非常不同，因为要处理机械故障、机械限制。你知道，你必须考虑，不仅仅是我处于值 1，我想处于值 2。你必须考虑状态之间的转换。比如我有一个伺服电机，伺服电机不会瞬间移动。所以如果我告诉它转到 90 度，然后到 50 度，然后到 70 度，好吧，它可能才刚刚开始移动。所以你必须考虑时间的推移和系统的限制。是的，我也发现这非常——我不知道，这与你指出的处理数据库或应用程序相比，是一个不同的挑战。是的，当然有一个——我想你可能触及到了某种滞后（hysteresis）的概念，
one and I want to be at value two. You have to think about how does a transition between, I guess we're calling it sort of states. Like I have a servo motor, a servo motor doesn't move instantaneously. So if I tell it to go to 90 degrees and then to 50 degrees and then to 70 degrees, well, it may still have only just started moving. So you got to think about sort of like the progression of time and the limits of the system. Yeah, I also find that very, I don't know, like a different challenge, I guess, than like you point out working with a database or an application. Yeah, yeah, certainly there's a like, I think you're, maybe you're getting at some, this notion of hysteresis,
这是我在构建系统时学到的，即系统中存在滞后，你想抵消它。是的，构建某种机制来应用这一点通常非常有用。是的，我不认为我们曾经深入讨论过控制回路。我不知道我现在是否想深入探讨。
which I learned when building the systems where there's like a lag in the system and you want to like counteract that. Yeah, building some sort of like mechanism for applying that is pretty useful in general. Yeah, we've never really talked, I don't think in depth or gone into about control loops. I don't know that I want to go there now.
那最终会成为一个独立的话题，但你知道，对某事物的控制。而且我认为你刚才也谈到了传感器、测量和观察，以便拥有某种控制回路。我认为这也是一个非常有趣的领域。我不知道你对此了解多少，但仅仅是思考当你观察世界时，它是相当嘈杂的，因为世界本身就是
That's going to end up being a whole topic into itself, but you know, control of something. And then I think you were talking as well about, you know, sort of sensors and measuring and, you know, observing in order to have a sort of a control loop. And I think that's also a really interesting field. You know, I don't know how much, how much you've gotten into it, but just sort of even thinking about when you observe the world, it's pretty noisy because the world itself is
嘈杂的，因为你的传感器有噪声，它们有局限性，而且了解这些局限性也很重要，这样你对世界运作方式的模型才能准确反映实际发生的情况。是的。是的。我认为这确实涉及到了这个概念，我想，比如一个平台或软件平台，你可以在其中有一个地方来摄取所有这些来自传感器的数据并跟踪它们。所以当你拥有一个机器人系统时，有所有这些必须跟踪的遥测数据，并且，你知道，也许从这些遥测数据中收集健康数据，或者利用遥测数据本身来进行某种高阶规划。这就是为什么拥有一个更广泛的、比如包含跟踪系统、数据摄取系统等的平台会非常有价值，
noisy because your sensors have noise and they have limits and, you know, knowing those as well so that you, your model of how the world works is accurate to what's actually happening. Yeah. Yeah. I think that does get into this notion of, I guess, like a platform or a software platform in which you can have a place to ingest all this data from sensors and track them. So when you have a robotic system, there's all this kind of telemetry that you must track and sort of, you know, maybe collect health data from that telemetry or use the telemetry itself to do some sort of high order planning. And that's kind of where, you know, having a like a broader, let's say, like platform that contain tracking systems, data ingestion systems, and so forth can be pretty valuable,
特别是当你构建一些简单的机器人应用时，它们在执行方面不一定非常复杂，但在理解它们所产生的信息方面却更复杂。有趣。哦，这又是另一个非常密集的信息，或者说是一种评论。所以，是的，你的意思是，你有传感器，你在收集信息，然后你在做一些对这些信息的理解。而且我想当你——你在收集信息，然后你在做一些对这些信息的理解。而且我想当你
especially when you're, you know, building, say, simpler robotics applications that are not necessarily very highly complex on, let's say, actuation, but are more complex on the side of making sense of the kind of information they are producing. Interesting. Oh, there's another like very densely packed sentence, I guess, or sort of sort of comment. So I guess so yeah, so what you're saying is, you have sensors, and you're collecting an information, then you're, you know, sort of doing some understanding of that information. And I guess when you were collecting an information, then you're, you know, sort of doing some understanding of that information. And I guess when you were sort of saying a platform or a framework for handling these things, that there are some parts of it and some flows which are common between applications.
在说处理这些事情的平台或框架时，有些部分和流程在应用程序之间是通用的。你是这个意思吗？是的，绝对是。所以你可以把很多这样的传感器平台看作是，比如你有一个智能家居，或者你有一些安全摄像头，甚至你有一个机器人，或者比如一架正在飞行的无人机。这些机器人之间有很多共同点。归根结底，这确实是关于从它们那里获取信息，把它们存储在某个地方，对它们进行分析，然后可能还要控制它们，并发送——从它们那里获取信息，把它们存储在某个地方，对它们进行分析，然后可能还要控制它们，并发送命令给这些各种
Is that sort of what you're getting at? Yeah, yeah, absolutely. So like you can sort of think of a lot of these like sensor platforms, like let's say you have a smart home or you have some sort of security camera or you even have like a robot or like, let's say a drone that's flying around. There's a lot of commonalities between these kinds of robots. At the end of the day, it really is about, you know, getting the information from them, storing them somewhere, performing analytics on them, and then also maybe controlling them and sending, you know, getting the information from them, storing them somewhere, performing analytics on them, and then also maybe controlling them and sending, you know, commands to these various
东西。所以这有点像，你可以从这个意义上思考，这就是共同点。而且你确实会在如今许多不同的应用领域看到很多这样的东西，从自动驾驶汽车到我们的无人机配送。所以，稍微离题一下，但当你这么说的时候，我被触动了。不久前有人向我介绍了一个概念，在更广泛的背景下听到它很有趣，
things. So it's kind of like, you can think of it in that sense, which is, yeah, that's sort of the commonalities, I guess. And you do actually end up seeing a lot of these in many different application areas these days from self-driving cars to our drone delivery. So a little bit of an aside, but when you were saying that, I was triggered. Someone introduced me to some concept a bit ago, and it's been kind of interesting to hear in a broader context,
因为我倾向于用控制回路的术语来思考它，因为我想这就是我第一次偶然发现它的地方。但这就是 OODA 循环。你以前听说过这个吗？不，那是什么？好的，所以 OODA 循环。你以前听说过这个吗？不，那是什么？好的，所以 OODA 循环，我想，
because I kind of think about it in the terms of control loops, because I guess that's where I first sort of stumbled across it. But this is the OODA loop. Have you heard of this before? No, what is that? Okay, so the OODA loop. Have you heard of this before? No, what is that? Okay, so the OODA loop, I guess,
是某样东西，我相信是一位美国空军上校提出的，这基本上是人类处理问题的一种方式。我相信他当时是在研究战斗机飞行员，思考决策过程。所以他提出了这个术语，OODA 循环。
is something that, I believe it was the United States Air Force Colonel came up with, which is basically like a way for humans to sort of tackle the problems. I believe he was doing sort of fighter pilots and thinking about the decision-making process. And so he came up with this term, this OODA loop.
所以它有四个步骤，OODA 的四个字母，O-O-D-A。即观察（Observe）、定位（Orient）、决策（Decide）、行动（Act）。所以他把它看作是一个在你大脑中持续运行的过程。你首先观察，然后定位自己，决定你要做什么，然后行动。然后你观察那个行动的输出，对吧？所以听到你描述这个，这有点离题，但来自——我想我们称之为“肉体空间”（meat space），比如人类和空军，拥有这个 OODA 循环。然后我听说它被应用于商业，对吧？以及做出商业决策。然后在这里，当我听到你谈论机器人时，我又想起了它，
So it's four steps, the four letters of OODA, O-O-D-A. It's observe, orient, decide, act. So he has it as this, you know, continual process that's running in your brain. You first observe, then you orient yourself, you decide what you're going to do, and then you act. Then you observe like the output of that action, right? And so hearing you describe this, this is somewhat of an aside, but coming from, I guess what we call that meat space, like humans and the Air Force and having this OODA loop. And then I've heard it applied to business, right? And making business decisions. And then here, I'm reminded of it again, when you sort of talk about robotics
以及你如何想要设置这个流程和这个循环。不，是的，实际上，既然你提到了，我基本上听说过完全一样的东西。所以现在想起来了。我认为那个行动循环是这类机器人系统的核心，特别是因为它们不仅必须在现实世界中做出决策，而且人类也可以根据从这些——
and about how you want to get this flow set up and this cycle set up. No, yeah, that's actually, now that you mentioned it, I have basically heard something exactly like that. So it does come to mind now. And that action loop is, I think, at the crux of these kinds of robotic systems, especially because both they have to make decisions in the real world, but also humans can make decisions based on the information collected from these,
比如机器人或传感器收集到的信息来做出决策。是的，是观察、定位、决策、行动，如果我没记错的话。是的，你可以把它们分解或映射到机器人系统或平台的各个组件中，比如，你摄取数据并收集它，也许你在平台的某个 Web UI 部分显示它。你知道，用户定位自己，然后也许他们发现了一些他们想要采取行动的信息，然后他们可以，你知道，把命令发回给机器人，
let's say, robots or sensors. And yeah, it's observe, orient, detect, act, if I got that right. And yeah, you can sort of break those down or map those into the various components of, let's say, a robotics system or platform where, yeah, you ingest data and you collect it and maybe you display it in some part of a web UI of your platform. You know, the user orients themselves and then maybe they find some information they want to act on and then they can sort of, you know, send the command back to the robot
并完成他们的工作。所以，是的，我认为在思考这类系统时，这绝对是正确的类比。我正在纠结是继续讨论你说的其余内容，还是提升一个层次，谈谈平台的所有不同组件，因为你已经开始暗示其中一些了。所以你提到了遥测、UI 显示组件、跟踪器。我很想深入探讨每一个，但我认为这可能会变得有点长。所以我们提到了一个平台。所以对你来说，在你心中，你使用这些平台以及驱动它的软件，
and get their work done. So, yeah, that's absolutely, I think, the right analogy when thinking of these kinds of systems. I'm debating with myself whether to go through the rest of the things you say, or to lift up a level and talk about all the different components of a platform, because you're already starting to allude to some. So you mentioned telemetry, the UI display component, trackers. I'm tempted to go into each of these, but I think that might become a little long. So we were mentioning a platform. So to you in your mind, like you work with these platforms and sort of the commonality between this and the software
有哪些——我不知道是否有某种规范的，比如这五个组件，或者只是——你看到的最常见的、在这些事物中都有用的组件是什么？但你能不能谈谈构成机器人平台的一些正常部分？绝对可以，是的。我想，在描述它们之前，我确实想澄清一下我们所说的“平台”概念到底是什么意思。因为在我脑海中，平台是某种能够支持应用程序的东西。随着你引入或支持的每个应用程序，未来的应用程序集成起来会更便宜或更容易。
that drives it. What are some of the, I don't know if there, if you have like a canonical sort of, there's these five components or just like, what are the most common ones that you see come up that are useful across these things but maybe could you talk a little to like what are the normal pieces that would make up sort of like a robotics platform absolutely yeah i guess uh there certainly are some commonalities before i describe them i do want to i guess like maybe sort of clarify what we even mean by this platform notion. Because in my head, platform is something that enables applications. And with each application you sort of introduce or is enabled with this platform, future applications are made cheaper or easier to integrate.
让我给你举一个平台可能是什么的例子。比如在软件世界中，你可以把 iPhone 看作一个平台，它支持了消费互联网，并且添加到 App Store 的每个应用程序都使未来的应用程序变得更容易，因为苹果可以扩展其功能、向应用开发者公开的 API，而且你还有这种生态系统效应。
Let me give you maybe an example of what a platform might be. So like normally like in the software world, you can think of, let's say, the iPhone as a platform, which is, you know, it enabled the consumer internet and sort of each application that was added to the App Store made future applications, let's say, easier because, you know, Apple could extend its functionality, the APIs it exposed to app developers, and you also had this ecosystem effect.
随着时间的推移，App Store 上的应用程序出现了爆炸式增长。所以，这就是我大致的意思。这有道理吗？是的，也许我在这里稍微离题一下，我把它复述给你，你看看是否有道理。所以我提到了涉足电子机器人之类的东西，只是作为一个业余爱好者。所以对我来说，其中一件非常有趣的事情是，即使我是一名程序员，而且我开始得很早，早于一些更现代的东西，你必须去为一个 ATmega 芯片寻找 C 编译器，
And over time, you had this explosion of apps on the App Store. So that's, I guess, what I roughly mean by platform. Does that make sense? Yeah, maybe I'll take a little bit of an aside here, and I'll tell it back to you, and you tell me if it makes sense. So I mentioned dabbling in electronics of like electronics robotics stuff as just like a hobbyist so for me uh one of the things that was really interesting is even though i was a programmer and i started very early predating some of the more modern stuff you would have to go and find a c compiler for an app mega
或者一个 ATtiny 芯片或其他什么，对吧？那是一个奇怪的平台。它有非常底层的库。为那个芯片编写程序非常困难。然后 Arduino 和 Raspberry Pi 出来了。所以对我来说，当我听到你这么说时，你描述的是不是像 Arduino 那样的东西？它是一个硬件集，但实际上，它是一个为你提供输入点的库。它为你提供了用于接收传感器数据、驱动电机等的库。而且你实际上可以在几个不同的平台上运行它，不仅仅是 Arduino 平台本身，甚至其他处理器也会适配该库，因为就像你说的，它加快了人们进入和进行集成并使应用程序更便宜的能力，因为大部分繁重的工作都为你完成了。绝对是。是的，这就是我所说的平台的意思。Arduino 当然符合这一点。
part and or an app now app now part what is8 or whatever, right? And it was some strange platform. It had very low level libraries. It was very hard to write for that chip. Then the Arduino Raspberry Pi came out. And so to me, like when I hear you say, you're describing, is that the something like an Arduino where it is, it is a hardware set, but in actuality, it's a library that gives you your sort of input point. It gives you libraries for taking in sensor data, for actuating sort of motors and whatever. And you actually can run it on several different, not just Arduino platforms themselves, but even other processors will adapt that library because like you were saying, it speeds up people's ability to get in and do integrations and make applications cheaper because so much of the lifting is done for you. Absolutely. Yeah, that's exactly what I mean by platforms. And Arduino certainly qualifies for
在硬件世界中有一个类似的平台叫 NVIDIA Tegra，我认为它几乎单枪匹马地推动了目前正在发生的边缘感知或边缘物联网革命。当然，原因和你提到的一样。它们为你做了很多繁重的工作。它们为你提供了可以实现感知算法的库。而且你显然还得到了带有 GPU 的板子。你可以直接把它拍在机器人上，现在你就有了边缘机器学习、边缘计算机视觉。所以，这就是平台的力量。所以我实际上对那个一无所知，你能说说吗？所以它是一个像 NVIDIA 的——所以我假设它意味着它上面有一个通用 GPU 处理设置，是
that. There is like a similar platform in the hardware world called NVIDIA Tegra, which has basically enabled, I think like single-handedly enabled the edge sort of edge perception or edge IoT revolution that's currently happening. And certainly it's for the same reasons you mentioned. They do a lot of heavy lifting for you. They give you libraries with which you can implement perception algorithms. And you also get the board obviously with the GPU attached to it. And you can literally slap it on a robot and now you have edge machine learning edge computer vision so uh that is the power of platforms so I actually don't know anything about that can you speak what so it's a like nvidia so I assume it means it has a sort of general purpose gpu processing setup on it is
那个吗？是的，那基本上是——我想——所以 NVIDIA 有这些你可以使用的板子。我想那里的杀手级应用是它是一块带有 GPU 的板子。这个想法是，你可以把它拍在边缘。所以它很小。它很紧凑。它功耗低。是的，它运行 Linux。它带有，你知道，是的，一个通用
that the yeah that's that's basically I think the So NVIDIA has these boards that you can use. And I guess the killer app there is it's a board with the GPU on it. And the idea is that it's something that you can slap on at the edge. So it's pretty small. It's compact. It's low power. And yeah, it runs Linux. And it comes with, you know, yeah, a general purpose
GPU，你可以在上面运行你想要的任何花哨的机器学习和计算机视觉算法。所以，再次强调，它的承诺是你不需要——比如，如果你有机器人或传感器上的帧或摄像机视频，NVIDIA Tegra 的承诺是你不需要把那些帧或视频发送到云端并在云端运行推理。你实际上可以在边缘完成它，这可以带来性能提升，
GPU on which you can run all the fancy machine learning and computer vision algorithms that you would want. So, and the promise of that again is you don't have to, let's say, if you have frames or camera video that you have on your robot or sensor, the promise of NVIDIA Tegra is that you don't have to ship those frames or video off to the cloud and run inference on the cloud. You can actually do it on the edge, which can yield performance improvements,
你知道，推理延迟更低等等。好的，这在这里也值得一提。所以“边缘”（edge）这个词不是两个节点之间的边缘，而是指进行观察的事物的“前沿”。是的，完全正确。所以，正如我所说，有边缘计算，然后有云计算。这就是这里的对比，你在哪里运行——
you know, much better latency on inference and so forth. Okay, that's probably worth a call as well here. So the word edge isn't an edge between two nodes, but edge is the like frontier of the the frontier of the thing doing the observations. Yes, exactly. So there's, as I can say, the edge compute and then there's cloud compute. And that's the contrast here where you run,
云是在某个地方的大仓库里的数据中心，而边缘是——它就在事情实际发生的地方，可以这么说。而且你的计算是分散在环境中的，而不是……是的，这就是这里的想法。所以这很有趣。我想在我的经验中，我主要遇到的是你所说的边缘计算，但边缘计算仅仅是边缘计算，没有云组件。
cloud is in a data center somewhere in a big warehouse, whereas the edge is, it's near, it's at the edge of where it's actually happening, so to speak. And you have compute that is sort of spread out across the environment rather than... Yeah, so that's the idea here. So that's pretty interesting. I guess in my experience, I've mostly encountered what you're calling edge compute, but edge compute as only edge compute, like there's no cloud component.
所以你是说，对于某些机器人应用，我想这说得通，是某种合作的——我不知道你会怎么称呼它们——机器人、通过……交互的代理。所以一些数据是在边缘和本地完成的，但随后一些被推送到云端，然后数据被推回并共享给其他？是的，绝对是。我认为这种分工非常强大。原因在于
So are you saying is that for some sort of robotics applications, I guess that makes sense, is sort of cooperating, I don't know what you would call them, robots, agents that interact through. So some data is done on the edge and in the local thing, but then some is pushed to the cloud and then data is pushed back out and shared across other? Yeah, absolutely. I think that division of labor is quite powerful. And the reason for this
有些应用有硬性限制。所以我提到的 NVIDIA Tegra 平台，你知道，你得到 4GB 的内存，甚至 GPU 也不一定——你不能在那里运行最大的模型。所以它在你能做什么方面有相当硬性的限制。例如，如果你想进行批量数据处理，那可能不是做这类事情的正确地方。但你可以从你所有的边缘传感器摄取数据，也许有一组边缘传感器在环境中渗透，做它们所有的工作。也许它们在仓库里，也许在建筑工地上等等。也许你确实想做分析。你想了解它们在做什么。你想得到一个报告，比如，我的整个车队表现如何？
is that there are applications that there's hard limits. So the NVIDIA Tegra platform I mentioned was, you know, you get four gigs of RAM and even the GPU is not necessarily, you can't run the largest models there. So it has pretty hard limits in terms of what you can do. So for example, if you want to do batch data processing, that's probably not the right place to do something like that. But you can ingest data from all your ad sensors and maybe have a fleet of ad sensors that are sort of like percolating the environment, doing all their work. Maybe they're in a warehouse, maybe in a construction site and so forth. Maybe you do want to do analytics. You want to understand what they're doing. You want to get like maybe a report of, you know, how is my fleet doing as a whole?
所以这些功能，你可以有一个数据摄取系统来获取所有这些数据，把它放到云端，并且，你知道，运行批量数据分析以及所有你可以在云端做的有趣的事情，这些在边缘是无法实现的。所以当你构建一个机器人平台时，这种分工非常强大。好的，所以我想你之前提到了它，但我猜我们在这里再次提到它。所以遥测（telemetry）。所以，我想在我的脑海中，那就像是发生了什么的记录或日志。在——我称之为机器人，因为我不知道更好的词。但在机器人中发生了什么，甚至像在赛车中，你知道，一些遥测数据是流式传输的，但有些可能会超过带宽。所以是本地记录的。
So those kinds of functions, you can have a data ingestion system to sort of get all that data, put it in the cloud and, you know, and run batch data analytics and all the, you know, all the fun stuff you can do in the cloud that wouldn't otherwise be possible at the edge. So that kind of division of labor is quite powerful when you're building a robotics platform. Okay, so I guess you brought it up earlier, but I guess we bring it up here again. So telemetry. So the, I guess, in my mind, that's sort of like the recording or log of what happened. Sort of in, I'll call it a robot, because I don't know better. But what happened in a robot, or even like in a race car, you know, some of the telemetry is streamed, but some of it may exceed the bandwidth. And so as recorded locally.
所以你的意思是，当你达到足够大的规模或商业规模时，这里也有一个组件，你想要对这些流进行进一步的处理和聚合。好的，是的，这说得通。好的。是的，是的。是的，这就是那个想法。你提到赛车很有趣，因为我认为一级方程式（F1）车队正在进入这个领域。所以他们正在使用，我想，
And so what you're saying is there's also a component here when you get to this at like a large enough scale or commercial scale where you want to do further processing and aggregation of those streams across. OK, yeah, that makes sense. All right. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's that's kind of the idea. It's funny you mentioned racing because I think that Formula One teams are getting into this. So they are using, I think,
Palantir 做了一个关于这个的发布，他们正在一级方程式上使用他们的软件。所以一级方程式车队正在获取他们的遥测数据，并使用 Palantir 的大数据分析工具来分析它。所以这完全就像是应用程序——车队正在获取他们的遥测数据，并使用 Palantir 的大数据分析工具来分析它。所以这完全就像是应用程序，
Palantir did like a release on this where they're using their software on Formula One. So Formula One teams are getting their telemetry and using Palantir's sort of big data analytics tools to analyze that. So that's exactly like the application teams are getting their telemetry and using Palantir's sort of big data analytics tools to analyze that. So that's exactly like the application that we are starting to see with this new sort of IoT or sensor evolution that's going on right now. Yeah, I saw this the other day. I just Googled it while you were talking because I wanted to get
我们开始看到这种新的物联网或传感器革命正在发生。是的，我前几天看到了这个。你说话的时候我刚用谷歌搜了一下，因为我想得到
some reasonable number. But an F1 car, they're saying has over 300 sensors. And it does something like just transmission from cars to the pits is over a million like data points per second. So I mean, even if each of those is only a byte, you're still like a megabyte of second data, which they're clearly not one byte each. Yeah, that's crazy. I'm not a big F1 fan, but I imagine they know all sorts of things about the car. Yeah, no, exactly. And I guess like going to the point of the, you know, bandwidth limitations, I often think about this a lot as well. We often, you know, when you have an edge network, it's not as ideal as having a data center wired connection, fiber, gigabit, so forth, where you can literally ship all that data. Often you're running on LTE or other kinds of
一些合理的数字。但是一辆 F1 赛车，他们说有超过 300 个传感器。它从赛车到维修站的传输量超过每秒一百万个数据点。所以，我的意思是，即使每个数据点只有一个字节，你仍然像每秒一兆字节的数据，它们显然不是每个一字节。是的，那太疯狂了。我不是 F1 的大粉丝，但我可以想象他们知道关于赛车的各种事情。是的，不，完全正确。而且我想说到带宽限制的问题，我也经常思考这个问题。我们经常，你知道，当你有一个边缘网络时，它不像拥有数据中心有线连接、光纤、千兆位等那样理想，在那里你可以真正发送所有这些数据。通常你是在 LTE 或其他类型的
lower bandwidth, less reliable links. And the amount of data that can be generated in theory is pretty large. So you do have this question of how do you process all the telemetry that you might see, let's say, on an F1 car in an efficient manner. And that in itself can be a pretty interesting data processing challenge. Or, yeah, it's a question of how do you efficiently get the useful information you need without, you know, hitting into hard limits of bandwidth and so forth. Today's sponsor for Programming Throwdown is SignalWire. SignalWire is a pretty awesome company that allows developers to use multiple languages to call their APIs and deliver low latency video and audio technology. So imagine if you're building an application or a website and you want to host an interactive event like a charity event that they supported for the American Cancer
低带宽、不太可靠的链路上运行。而且理论上可以产生的数据量相当大。所以你确实面临一个问题，即如何以有效的方式处理你可能在 F1 赛车上看到的遥测数据。这本身可能是一个非常有趣的数据处理挑战。或者，是的，这是一个关于如何有效地获取你需要的有用信息，而不触及带宽等硬性限制的问题。今天的 Programming Throwdown 赞助商是 SignalWire。SignalWire 是一家非常棒的公司，它允许开发者使用多种语言调用他们的 API，并提供低延迟的视频和音频技术。所以想象一下，如果你正在构建一个应用程序或网站，并且你想举办一个互动活动，比如他们支持的美国癌症
Society, where they're able to have multiple rooms, people interacting in the rooms, like a video conference call, but like way more tailored to your specifications and so much more flexibility and the APIs that enable you to do that. They're already being used by large TV studios, film companies, Fortune 500. These are all things that are definitely been battle tested. And today we are happy to have them as a sponsor of Programming Throwdown.
协会的慈善活动，在那里他们能够拥有多个房间，人们在房间里互动，就像视频会议通话，但更符合你的规格，并且有更多的灵活性，以及使你能够做到这一点的 API。它们已经被大型电视演播室、电影公司、财富 500 强公司使用。这些都是绝对经过实战检验的东西。今天我们很高兴有他们作为 Programming Throwdown 的赞助商。
Yeah, SignalWire provides expert support from the real OGs of software-defined telecom. These are the original geeks of that technology. SignalWire is a complete unified platform for integrating video as well as voice and messaging capabilities into any app. You could try it today at SignalWire.com and use code THROWDOWN for $25 in developer credit.
是的，SignalWire 提供来自软件定义电信领域真正 OG 的专家支持。这些是该技术的原始极客。SignalWire 是一个完整的统一平台，用于将视频以及语音和消息功能集成到任何应用程序中。你今天可以在 SignalWire.com 上尝试它，并使用代码 THROWDOWN 获得 25 美元的开发者信用额度。
So you go to SignalWire.com and use the code THROWDOWN at SignalWire.com today to receive $25 in developer credit. Now back to our episode. So talking about hard limits there and maybe a bit of my background. I mean, I think like I start to when you say there's difference between sort of edge compute and cloud compute, and I start to think about decisions that need to be made under a given timeline. Right. So we're talking about like control loops, right? There's hard real time limits if you want certain performance out of your loop. So like when you start to mix in these sort of like not guaranteed bandwidth streams and cloud compute, are you able to still do any sort of like real time guarantees? Or is it sort of
所以你今天去 SignalWire.com 并使用代码 THROWDOWN，即可获得 25 美元的开发者信用额度。现在回到我们的节目。所以谈到那里的硬性限制以及我的一点背景。我的意思是，我想我开始——当你说是边缘计算和云计算之间有区别时，我开始思考需要在给定时间轴下做出的决策。对吧。所以我们谈论的是控制回路，对吧？如果你想从你的回路中获得某种性能，就有硬实时限制。所以当你开始混合这些所谓的非保证带宽流和云计算时，你还能做任何形式的实时保证吗？还是它
become a much softer thing? Yeah, yeah, that's a that's an interesting point. And something I've firstly run into when building these complex robotic systems is a few different points there I noted, but to riff on the, you know, guaranteed delivery, for I would say one of the primary concerns for me, when I was building, like actual robotic systems that do fly and do actual things. And it's like something I would always have at the back of my head whenever I'm writing, let's say, for loop that acts on external data. It's like I have to think about, you know, what if this data does not actually arrive? What if I miss measurements that would have been otherwise critical in my decision making? So one of the patterns that I ended up adopting over time is
变成了一个更软的东西？是的，是的，这是一个有趣的观点。这也是我在构建这些复杂的机器人系统时首先遇到的事情，我注意到了几个不同的点，但要谈论保证交付，对于我来说，当我构建真正会飞行并做实际事情的机器人系统时，我会说这是主要关注点之一。每当我编写作用于外部数据的 for 循环时，我总是会把它记在心里。就像我必须考虑，你知道，如果这些数据实际上没有到达怎么办？如果我错过了在我的决策中本应至关重要的测量结果怎么办？所以我最终采用的模式之一是
sort of focusing a lot of idempotence and sort of writing my code or structuring my code in a way in which I would get almost like eventual behavior. So eventually, my robot would do certain things. So it would tend towards things rather than depending on exact delivery of messages, if that makes sense. Yeah, I mean, I guess for like, maybe just to kind of illustrate it for other people. So when you're building a video game, people know like, oh, you're trying to hit a certain frames per second, say it's 30 frames per second, or 60 frames per second. And so various parts, maybe this isn't obvious, but various parts of the system get budgets, right? So the AI for path planning for all of the bad guys, right? That has like a budget for how long it can take to run. There's a, how long it can take for you to do
专注于幂等性（idempotence），并以一种我几乎能得到最终行为的方式编写代码或构建代码。所以最终，我的机器人会做某些事情。所以它会趋向于某些事情，而不是依赖于消息的精确交付，如果这说得通的话。是的，我的意思是，我想对于——也许只是为了给其他人说明一下。所以当你构建一个视频游戏时，人们知道，哦，你试图达到一定的每秒帧数，比如每秒 30 帧或 60 帧。所以系统的各个部分，也许这不明显，但系统的各个部分都有预算，对吧？所以所有坏人的路径规划 AI，对吧？它有一个运行需要多长时间的预算。有一个，你做
determining all the polygons you need to render. Everything gets a budget because you have a timeline. But for things like robotics, the difference is instead of dropping a frame of video or having a stutter, which is not ideal, and that's very serious work, if you're flying a quadcopter and you have your motors need to have a certain signal sent at a certain rate
确定你需要渲染的所有多边形需要多长时间。一切都有预算，因为你有一个时间轴。但对于机器人技术之类的事情，区别在于，与其丢弃一帧视频或出现卡顿——这并不理想，而且是非常严肃的工作——如果你在驾驶四轴飞行器，并且你的电机需要以一定的速率发送一定的信号
to control how fast the props are spinning, if you miss one of those, the issue is that like the system isn't going to behave like you thought it would. Like there is a how fast you need to respond to an input from either the vehicle itself or from a human controller if they're in the loop for the system to behave as you've sort of modeled it. So I guess in some systems, you get these deadlines, which are very serious to the operation. That was super vague. But like, if you imagine a robot arm,
来控制螺旋桨旋转的速度，如果你错过了其中一个，问题在于系统不会像你想象的那样运行。对于系统按照你建模的方式运行，你需要多快响应来自车辆本身或人类控制器的输入（如果他们在回路中）。所以我想在某些系统中，你会得到这些截止日期，这对操作来说非常严肃。这太模糊了。但比如，如果你想象一个机器人手臂，
you know, moving around the world, and if it sees a person step into its path, if there isn't a guarantee that you can see with your camera or sensor that the person is now in the danger zone and stop the robot within 100 milliseconds. If you end up with a garbage collection running during that time and you end up with a 50 millisecond delay, then all of a sudden you can't guarantee the safety of humans around that robot. No, I think that's exactly, that's a pretty big concern when you're building robots, especially those that interact with the real world and are near humans and or are doing similarly like life critical stuff.
在世界上四处移动，如果它看到一个人走进它的路径，如果没有保证你能用你的摄像头或传感器看到那个人现在在危险区域，并在 100 毫秒内停止机器人。如果你在那段时间内运行垃圾回收，并且最终出现了 50 毫秒的延迟，那么突然之间你就无法保证机器人周围人类的安全。不，我认为这完全正确，当你构建机器人时，这是一个相当大的担忧，特别是那些与现实世界互动、靠近人类和/或做类似生命关键任务的机器人。
So I guess one pattern that shows up when you're trying to build systems like that is you want to have, let's say like a safety layer. So you want to actually break up your system into say the functional layer and the safety layer. And you want to keep these pieces quite like decoupled. And the safety layer is something that kicks in whenever let's say your telemetry goes off or whatever, if it thinks that something is off, that it's not receiving the information it needs to be receiving, the safety layer should kick in
所以我认为当你试图构建这样的系统时，会出现一种模式，即你想要拥有，比如一个安全层。所以你实际上想把你的系统分解为功能层和安全层。而且你想要保持这些部分相当解耦。安全层是每当你的遥测数据异常，或者无论它认为有什么不对劲，如果它认为它没有收到它需要收到的信息，安全层就应该介入。
and hopefully you have like a path to say safe exit. And I would say this seems like a probably a pattern that you see across drones, robotic arms in manufacturing, or even probably self-driving cars where you want to like safely stop. And if your sensor systems are malfunctioning or your telemetry is off and so forth. So, yeah, I found that pattern pretty useful in general. Yeah, I guess like these topics get pretty involved, like how you sort of guarantee safety, especially if you start talking about various certification organizations who want to, you know, safety certify something or medical equipment like a pacemaker, not only like having it be safe, but proving that it'll be safe becomes quite an involved process, I guess.
希望你有一种所谓的路径来确保安全退出。我想说，这似乎是你在无人机、制造业机器人手臂，甚至可能是自动驾驶汽车中经常看到的模式，即你希望能够安全地停止。如果你的传感器系统出现故障，或者遥测数据不准确等等。所以，是的，我发现这种模式在一般情况下非常有用。是的，我想这些话题会变得非常复杂，比如你如何保证安全性，特别是当你开始谈论各种认证机构时，他们想要对某些东西进行安全认证，或者像心脏起搏器这样的医疗设备，不仅要让它安全，而且要证明它是安全的，这变成了一个相当复杂的过程，我想。
No, absolutely. You know, maybe that's a domain topic and formal verification. That could be an interesting area. I haven't looked too much into it. But yeah, certainly, like you would have to prove that your software will work under these, in these constraints and show them your source code and so forth. Yeah, I haven't personally been through that process so far, but yeah, I imagine it's a tough problem. At least, you know, one thing I do is really like very defensive programming when I build some of these systems is default to nothing or, you know, landing if I'm running a drone,
不，绝对是这样。你知道，也许这是一个领域课题，形式化验证。这可能是一个有趣的领域。我还没有深入研究过。但确实，你必须证明你的软件在这些约束条件下能够工作，并向他们展示你的源代码等等。是的，我个人目前还没有经历过那个过程，但我想这是一个难题。至少，我做的一件事是，在构建这些系统时，我真的会进行非常防御性的编程，即默认什么都不做，或者，如果我正在运行一架无人机，
for example, if nothing, or returning to base, which is the other concept in drones. But yeah, so always having that default fallback pattern helps you have that kind of defensiveness without, you know, requiring formal verifications. Yeah, yeah, I've had incidental contact with some of this a couple of times. I guess formal verification where you sort of have like approvably correct, or at least for one definition, like approvably correct way of coding or design spec. And you have certain axioms
例如，如果什么都没有，或者返回基地，这是无人机中的另一个概念。但是，是的，所以始终拥有那种默认的后备模式有助于你拥有那种防御性，而不需要形式化验证。是的，是的，我偶尔接触过这些东西几次。我想形式化验证是指你拥有一种可证明正确，或者至少在某种定义下是可证明正确的编码或设计规范。并且你有一些公理
and you guarantee those axioms are met. I've actually never come across a system that tried to tackle the problem that way, although I know people do do it. It's an interesting field. But yeah, what I've seen more common is, I guess, sort of similar to what you're doing, this defensive programming, which is you could talk about things like C or C++ coding standards and what you're allowed to do. So one of the easiest to understand ones is it's very common if you're using, I'll use C++, that's what I'm familiar with. If you're using the C++ standard library, right?
并且你保证这些公理得到满足。我实际上从未遇到过试图以这种方式解决问题的系统，尽管我知道人们确实在这样做。这是一个有趣的领域。但是，是的，我看到更常见的是，我想，类似于你正在做的这种防御性编程，也就是你可以谈论像 C 或 C++ 编码标准以及你被允许做什么。所以最容易理解的其中之一是，如果你正在使用——我将使用 C++，这是我熟悉的——如果你正在使用 C++ 标准库，对吧？
And you have an STL vector and you're inserting something, it's actually allocating as you're inserting, it's allocating extra and moving stuff around, it's doing a lot of work. And if you're doing that inside of a loop, you can end up with a lot of performance issues because when the memory goes to be freed,
你有一个 STL 向量，并且你正在插入一些东西，它实际上是在你插入时进行分配，它分配了额外的空间并移动东西，它做了很多工作。如果你在一个循环中这样做，你最终可能会遇到很多性能问题，因为当内存被释放时，
what the allocator does or doesn't do at that time period isn't very easy to reason about. Or what if you ran out of memory because you didn't do it? So one of the techniques there in this sort of, you mentioned defensive programming, is do all of your allocations up front. So figure out what you're going to need, do them at the very beginning. That way the system either fails to start up
分配器在那个时间段做了什么或没做什么，并不是很容易推理。或者如果你因为没有这样做而耗尽了内存怎么办？所以这里的一种技术，在你提到的防御性编程中，就是预先完成所有的分配。所以弄清楚你需要什么，在最开始就完成它们。这样系统要么启动失败，
or once it starts up, you sort of know no more allocations. And I've seen that be done even to the point where the allocator is effectively turned off after like some phase of the startup cycle. And anything that tries to allocate is like guaranteed to not work. Yeah. Yeah. I think C++ even makes it pretty easy for you with the reserve keyword. I'm not sure you're familiar with that. But yeah, you can like reserve space before you even add to the vector. So certainly, that's a pretty good pattern in C++ defensive programming. But you could also do defense not necessarily on the, let's say the code level, but you could also do it on a process level, which is, let's say, more coarse, but easier to manage. consuming at any given time. And you can sort of like manage the processes running on your compute board in a way that you just kill, let's say the, the application processes whenever
要么一旦启动，你就知道不会再有分配了。我甚至见过这种情况，分配器在启动周期的某个阶段之后实际上被关闭了。任何试图分配内存的行为都被保证不会成功。是的。是的，我认为 C++ 甚至通过 reserve 关键字让你很容易做到这一点。我不确定你是否熟悉它。但是，是的，你可以在添加到向量之前预留空间。所以当然，这是 C++ 防御性编程中一个非常好的模式。但你也可以进行防御，不一定是在代码层面，你也可以在进程层面进行防御，这可以说更粗糙，但更容易管理。在任何给定时间消耗的资源。你可以以某种方式管理在你的计算板上运行的进程，即你只是杀掉，比如说，应用程序进程，无论
maybe they're going off the rails for whatever reason, so that the, um, the backup or the safety processes, uh, should have enough, enough memory so that the drone can return home or the robot can safely reset to a safe state. So I also do end up thinking a lot on these various levels of abstraction of the system where you kind of separate it out. So it's maybe like a shortcut or easier way to build more systems, but the alternative is to be super careful with how your C++ is structured, which can be pretty hard. hard and c++ is a is a beast of its own well yeah let's not get into that yeah yeah so you bring up another interesting point there so managing you know processes and
也许它们因为某种原因失控了，这样备份或安全进程应该有足够的内存，以便无人机可以返回基地，或者机器人可以安全地重置到安全状态。所以我最终也会在系统的这些不同抽象层面上思考很多，你把它们分离开来。所以这可能是一种构建更多系统的捷径或更简单的方法，但另一种选择是对你的 C++ 结构方式极其小心，这可能非常困难。困难，而且 C++ 本身就是一个庞然大物。好吧，是的，我们不要深入讨论那个。是的，是的，所以你在那里提出了另一个有趣的观点。所以管理，你知道，进程和
and sort of like the approach of of making sure that things stay within their limits i guess that's an interesting thing too so when we talk about something like tagra and you mentioned like, oh, running Linux and having that kind of stuff, is it in your experience? Like, I mean, is it mostly very familiar, like Linux operating systems with all the sort of programmer ergonomics you would normally see related to that? Or are a lot of the times you're interacting with devices that have more specialized operating systems? Right. No, that's a good question. I would say the main difference is actually the architecture, which is maybe not that different these days since you have ARM on Mac, but the NBGiTegra platform is an ARM thing. And normally your Linux running in cloud or on your desktop is an x86
以及确保事情保持在限制范围内的那种方法，我想那也是一件有趣的事情。所以当我们谈论像 Tegra 这样的东西时，你提到，哦，运行 Linux 并拥有那种东西，在你的经验中是这样吗？我的意思是，它主要是非常熟悉的，像带有你通常会看到的与此相关的所有程序员人体工程学的 Linux 操作系统吗？还是很多时候你是在与拥有更专业操作系统的设备进行交互？对。不，这是一个好问题。我想主要的区别实际上是架构，这在今天可能并没有那么大的不同，因为 Mac 上有 ARM，但 NVIDIA Tegra 平台是一个 ARM 东西。通常你在云端或桌面上运行的 Linux 是 x86
architecture. So that ends up being like probably the biggest difference in terms of the development environment that is exposed to people. That being said, you also want to do want to be careful in terms of how you sort of structure your operating system on the robot itself. And by that, I mean, you know, while the intricacies of compiling a program on Linux is that there's no guarantee that you get the same artifact when you compile it on, let's say, your cloud computer or your desktop. And they could be the same architecture, but, you know, the intricacies of like your package
架构。所以这最终成为人们所接触到的开发环境方面最大的区别。话虽如此，你也要小心你在机器人本身上构建操作系统的方式。我的意思是，虽然在 Linux 上编译程序的复杂性在于，当你把它在，比如说，你的云计算机或你的桌面上编译时，不能保证你得到相同的工件。它们可能是相同的架构，但是，你知道，你的包管理和你在 Linux 上设置的所有路径的复杂性，那些基本上意味着编译后的工件是完全不同的。这可能意味着存在像内存管理问题甚至 CPU 问题这样的复杂性，你可能会遇到这些问题。所以我想说，这是一个很大的挑战领域。而且我们确实有，如今确实有非常好的工具来处理这个问题。我不知道你是否想深入探讨，但有一个东西叫 Nix。我不知道你是否听说过它，但它确实解决了这种问题。所以我猜你在这里谈论的是，也许这个词是做可重现或密封的构建，这样你就知道如果每个工程师都做同样的事情。
management and all the paths you have set up on your Linux, those can basically mean that the compiled artifacts are completely different. And it could mean that there are intricacies like the memory management problems or even CPU problems you can run into from that. So that is, I would say, a big area of challenge. And we do have, there are actually pretty good tools these days to deal with that. And I don't know if you want to go into that, but there is this thing called Nix. I don't know if you've heard of it, but it does solve this kind of problem. So I guess what you're talking about here, and maybe the word is like doing reproducible or hermetic builds so that you know that if every engineer does the same thing.
所以我听说过人们使用 Docker 来应对这个挑战，但你提到了这个 Nix。那么什么是 Nix？是的，是的。所以我认为 Nix 是，再次，我认为他们的目标是准确地解决你提到的问题，即你想要有一个密封的可重现构建，所以当两个程序员在构建一个工件时，它会产生相同的工件，所以是的，你应该能够证明这一点，因为如果你，如果你可以对二进制文件或类似的东西或输出，构建工件进行哈希处理，并且它们有相同的
So I've heard of people using sort of Docker to tackle the challenge, but you were mentioning this Nix. So what is Nix? Yeah, yeah. So I think Nix is, again, like, I think their goal is to solve precisely the problem you mentioned, which is you want to have a hermetical reproducible build, so when two programmers are building an artifact, it results in the same artifact, so yeah, and you should be able to prove that because if you, if you can hash the binary or something or the out, the build artifact and they have the same
哈希值，你可以比较它们等等。Nix 通过提供一个，Nix 是一种允许你构建东西的编程语言来解决这个问题。而且，你知道，你可以指定，嘿，这是我的源代码。这是构建说明。这些是我的构建输入。所以如果你需要 CMake 或其他，你知道，你需要 Bazel 或任何东西来构建你的东西，你可以指定那些输入。然后它输出的是一个带有哈希值的工件。你可以构建任何东西。你可以使用 Nix 构建一个文本文件。所以你可以说，
hash and you can compare those and so forth. Nix tackles this problem by, you know, providing a, Nix is a programming language that allows you to build things. And, you know, it will, you can sort of like specify, Hey, this is my source code. This is the way these are the build instructions. These are the inputs to my build. So if you need CMake or other, you know, you need Bazel or whatever to build your things, you can specify those inputs. And then what it outputs is an artifact with a hash. You could build anything. You could build a text file using Nix. So you could say,
构建说明，只需将此文本复制粘贴到文本文件中，输出就是 build.txt。但优点是你运行相同的，比如说它被称为派生，这个概念，你指定派生，它是构建的蓝图。这里的关键点是，当你在两台计算机上运行此派生时，两个开发人员运行相同的派生，
build instruction, just copy paste this text into a text file and the output is build.txt. But the advantage is that you run the same, let's say it's called derivation, the concept, you specify derivation, which is the blueprint of a build. And the key bin here is when you run this derivation on two computers, two developers running the same derivation,
他们得到完全相同的输出。如果他们没有，他们可以通过比较哈希值来验证这一点。所以这正是它启用的关键功能。有趣。是的，所以我猜也许人们已经运行过这个了。我也看到这种情况出现，因为人们在做 Python 东西时遇到了，它只是会抓取你安装到系统的任何东西，而你不知道有什么依赖项，所以你把它发给别人，他们会说，这不起作用。所以人们使用像带有 pip 和需求文件的虚拟环境，指定我想要使用这个版本的库。我想你所说的是，Nix 不仅能为单个应用程序做到这一点，而且实际上能为操作系统本身做到这一点。是的，是的，我对你能领会这一点印象非常深刻。所以这正是
they get the exact same output. And if they don't, they can verify this by comparing the hash. So that is sort of the key feature it enables. Interesting. Yeah, so I guess maybe people have run this. I've seen this also come up as people doing Python stuff run into, it just will grab whatever you installed
这里的想法，即你不一定非要让你的构建目标成为一个文本文件或二进制文件，但你实际上可以用这种方式构建一个操作系统。你提到了 Python 虚拟环境，你知道，是的，你可以指定 requirements.txt，但随后假设你想要设置一个实际上并不简单的 Python 虚拟环境。我实际上在启动虚拟环境并安装我的 requirements.txt 时遇到了很多困难，无论出于什么原因。但 Nix 实际上让你在文件集中定义所有这些。甚至还有一个模块的概念。所以你可以将你的操作系统分解成各种模块。而且你实际上可以拥有一个描述操作系统的存储库。这让你能够可重现地
to your system and you don't know what dependencies, so you send it to someone else and they're like, this doesn't work. So then people use sort of like virtual environments with pip and a requirements file that specifies I want this version of the library to be used. And I guess what you're saying is so Nix is able to do that for more than just, you know, a single application, but actually for the operating system itself. Yeah, yeah, I'm very impressed that you're able to pick that up. So that's exactly the
构建这些操作系统。我认为这非常重要，特别是在你构建这些资源受限的边缘机器人时，你确实关心什么是大工件，你确实关心你在操作系统中拥有的有限资源。拥有这种可重现性基本上让你消除了在调试应用程序时可能拥有的无数坏变量。所以我认为这是一个非常强大的工具。好吧，我可能会稍微转换一下话题，我想。所以我们一直在谈论一点，我想，像非常底层的部分，对吧？所以像操作系统，实时约束。但我认为我，
the idea here, which is that you don't necessarily have to have your build target as a text file or a binary, but you can literally build an operating system in this manner. You mentioned sort of Python virtual environments and, you know, yeah, you can specify requirements.txt, but then say you want to set up a Python virtual environment that is actually non-trivial. Like I actually struggle a lot with getting a virtual environment going and installing my requirements.txt for whatever reason. But Nix actually lets you have all of this defined in a set of files. There's even a notion of modules. So you can decompose your operating system into various modules. And you can literally have a repository that describes an operating system. and that lets you reproducibly
那是我的背景。所以我对谈论那个很感兴趣。但我不想失去你之前给出的背景，你说的是在多种不同类型的机器人、同一个机器人的多个实例之间进行思考，并将其视为一个平台，而不仅仅是，你知道，一个单独的，你说的是像一个边缘代理，而是跨越更多。然后你还提到了像甚至在数据上做像图像识别这样的事情，你知道，你可能做的其他更大的任务。所以当你为自己思考时
build these operating systems. And it's a huge deal, I think, especially when you're building these resource-constrained edge robots where you really do care about what are the big artifacts, you really do care about the limited resources you have in an operating system. And having that reproducibility basically lets you eliminate the myriad of bad variables you could have when debugging application. So I think it's a really powerful tool. Well, I'm going to maybe segue a bit, I guess. So we've been talking about a little bit of, I guess, sort of like the very low level parts, right? So like the operating system, real time constraints. But I think I sort of,
并且你正在描述这个平台以及可能进入其中的东西，除了仅仅像配置单个机器人及其通信之外，还有哪些其他东西会进入其中？除了仅仅像配置单个机器人及其通信之外，还有哪些其他东西会进入那个平台？不，绝对是这样。是的，我们在那里跑题了。所以感谢你引导我们回来。那确实是一个很长的题外话。但是，是的，我认为有几个大组件。我不确定我是否认为它们一定是机器人技术所独有的。但假设有一条 Jack Power 线，事件实时发生。
that's sort of my background. So I'm interested in talking about that. But I don't want to lose the context you were giving earlier, where you were saying sort of thinking about across multiple different kinds of robots, multiple instances of the same robot and thinking about as a platform and more than just, you know, an individual, you were saying like an edge agent, but like across more. And then you were also mentioning stuff like even doing sort of like image recognition on the data, you know, the kinds of other bigger tasks that you might do. So when you think for yourself
所以任何实时发生的事情都可以以这种方式思考，或者我将描述的平台的这些组件，理论上你可以应用它们。所以我认为有几个关键组件。我认为系统，我们已经讨论过了，当你考虑，比如说，部署机器人车队时，这当然是一个关键组件。所以你确实想要拥有这些系统，并且你想要拥有这些系统的安装。所以谈到软件或工件的安装，
and you were sort of describing this platform and things that might go in it, what are some of the other things besides just like sort of configuring a single robot and its communication that would go in it. What are some of the other things besides just like sort of configuring a single robot and its communication that would go into that platform? No, absolutely. Yeah, we did take a digression there. So thanks for redirecting us. It was a long digression, for sure. But yeah, I think there's a few big components. And I'm not sure I think of them as necessarily being unique to robotics. but let's say there's a Jack Power line where events happen in real time.
有部署的概念，你可以把它看作 CI/CD 中的 D。是的，主要的担忧是，好的，你正在构建软件，你有迭代周期，开发人员不断地进行更新，你知道，在某种新时代的开发中，而不是企业软件的旧时代，在那里你可能会发布一张 CD 或类似的东西，或者一旦你编码了几个月就发布一个单一的构建工件。如今，我们不那样编程。我们对持续集成感兴趣，
So anything that happens in real time can be sort of thought of in this way, or these components of the platforms that I will describe, you could, in theory, apply them. So I think there's a few key components. I think systems, which you already discussed, is certainly one key component when you're thinking about, let's say, deploying a fleet of robots. So you do want to own the systems and you want to own the installation of those. So getting to installation of software or artifacts,
持续部署。所以部署成为运行这些传感器平台的关键方面。是的，其他方面是模拟，这有点像在云环境中模拟机器人车队。有数据基础设施，你知道，这些是数据生成系统。你如何摄取它们？
there's the notion of deployment, which is, you can think of it as the D in CI, CD. Yeah, the main concern is, okay, you're building software, you have iteration cycles, developers are constantly making updates, you know, in the sort of new age of development, as opposed to the old age of enterprise software, where you would maybe release a CD or something, or a single build artifact once you have done coding for months. These days, we don't do programming that way. We are interested in continuous integration,
你如何对它们进行分析？你如何，你知道，运行像你之前提到的图像检测？最后，还有一种网络组件，即这些机器人必须通过网络进行通信，你不能用电线连接它们。我的意思是，即使你确实用电线连接它们，那仍然是一个网络。所以总有一个通信网络方面。最后，还有为这些机器人构建客户端和 API。而你可以构建它的理想方式有哪些？
continuous deployment. So deployment becomes a key aspect of running these sensor platforms. And yeah, the other aspects are simulation, which is sort of simulating the robotic fleet in the cloud environment. There's data infrastructure, which is, you know, these are data generating systems. How do you ingest those?
所以我认为这五六个领域大致是构建这样一个平台的关键或核心组件。你会发现这些模式几乎存在于你看到的任何机器人、物联网或传感器平台中，无论是来自亚马逊、微软还是任何其他公司，真的。所以我将尽我所能一个一个地去谈论它们，并给我们一个机会谈论也许每一个。所以部署，我想对我来说，我想到了火星探测器，不，有一个问题。
How do you perform analytics on those? How do you, you know, run image detection like you were mentioning earlier? And finally, there's sort of like a networking component, which is these robots have to communicate over a network and you can't wire them. I mean, even if you did wire them, that would still be a network. So there's always a communications networking aspect. And finally, there's building clients and APIs for these robots. And what are some of the ideal ways in which you can structure that?
我们不知道出了什么问题。而且，我们需要运行一个构建并发送它。我想我也会在这里谈论模拟。所以有一些问题。火星探测器停止移动。某个可怜的男人或女人必须出现在办公室，然后，弄清楚如何不在另一个星球上搁浅价值数十亿美元的设备。然后，但最终所有这些
So I would say these five or six areas are roughly key or core components of building such a platform. And you will see these patterns across pretty much any robotics or IoT or sensor platform you see, whether it's from Amazon or Microsoft or any other company, really. So I'm going to try my best to go one by one to them and sort of like give us a chance to talk about maybe each one. So the deployment, I guess like for me, I think about the Mars rovers and, no, there's a problem.
发生了，有人必须部署二进制文件。对，对。不，这正是挑战所在。有趣的是你提到了这一点，因为我正在和过去做过类似工作的同事进行完全相同的对话。所以你的描述非常准确。当然在火星的情况下，挑战相当复杂，因为我认为它不是，通信本身不是瞬时的。所以它需要几分钟或类似的时间，30 分钟，
We don't know what's wrong. And like, we need to run a build and send it. I guess I'll talk about simulation here as well. So there's some issue. The Mars rover stops moving. Some poor guy or girl has to show up to the office and like, figure out how not to strand multi-billion dollar, like piece of equipment on another planet. And then but eventually all that
我想，如果我没记错的话，从地球到火星获取一些数据包。当然，你知道，他们不一定面临持续集成、持续部署的挑战，你知道，我们有，他们有一群程序员每天或每周都在发布软件，但当然，修补错误的问题非常重要，因为当你拥有这些机器人或传感器车队时，它们基本上就在环境之外，除非你派出一个现场服务
happens, and someone has to deploy the binary. Right, right. No, that's exactly the challenge. It's funny that you mentioned that because I was having the exact same conversation, the colleague who did work on similar stuff in the past. So it's eerily accurate, your description. And certainly in the Mars case, the challenge is quite complex because I think it's not, like the communication itself is not instantaneous. So it takes a few minutes or something, 30 minutes,
代理去修理它，否则它们会在那里度过一生。在火星的情况下，那是后勤噩梦。它可以被很好地理解。我想给埃隆打电话。你现在必须给埃隆或贝佐斯打电话，如果他们正在飞行的话。但是，是的，所以我认为部署确实为你解决了那个问题。而且这是一个很大的领域，或者是一个深入思考如何向你的车队交付软件的领域。所以我猜我有两个问题。所以，第一个我们谈论了一点关于将你的系统划分开来，拥有一个安全部分，然后是正常部分，并互相监控。但随后我想对于部署来说，也总是存在一种风险，如果你正在进行持续部署，比如当然你测试了它，但可能会有不同的东西或者
I think, if I'm remembering correctly, to get like some packets from Earth to Mars. And certainly like, you know, they don't necessarily have the challenges of continuous integration, continuous deployment where, you know, we have, they have a fleet of coders who are releasing software every day or every week, but certainly the, the question of patching bugs is quite important because when you have these robot or sensor fleets, they are basically out there in the environment and they are there for their lifetime unless you send a field service
一些故障，或者一个位被翻转，因为无论什么中微子飞过并交换了你机器人中的一个位，你如何处理那种过度部署并意外发布坏东西的风险？是的，是的。我认为构建良好部署软件的一个关键方面是构建良好的回滚软件或取消部署你的软件。是的。所以当你对你的边缘进行软件更新时，你必须构建，你必须摄取我们之前提到的遥测数据，你必须拥有设计良好的健康检查，这些检查会为你捕获错误并自动回滚。机器人技术的部署略有不同
agent to go and fix it. In the case of Mars, that's the logistical nightmare. It can be well understood. Call up Elon, I guess. You have to call up Elon or Bezos these days if they're taking a flight. But yeah, so I think deployment sort of does solve that problem for you. And it is a big area or a deep area of thinking about how do you deliver software to your fleet? So I guess like two questions I have there. So like the first we were talking a little bit about like compartmentalizing your system and having like a safety part and then like the normal part and monitoring each other. But then I guess for deployment as well, like there's always a risk that if you're doing continuous deployment, like sure you tested it, but that there could be something different or
从云部署来看，因为云总是连接的。你总是知道会有网络链路。回滚很容易。你甚至不需要，比如说，在云端的边缘有回滚工件。我的意思是，你可以直接重新发送最新的工件或你想要回滚到的先前工件。
some glitch or a bit gets flipped because whatever neutrino flies through and like swaps a bit in your robot, like how, how do you handle the sort of like risk of over deploying and accidentally shipping something that's bad? Yeah, yeah. I think a key aspect of building good deployment software is building good rollback software or undeploying your software. Yeah. So when you make a software update onto your edge, you have to build you have to be ingesting that telemetry we previously mentioned, you have to be, having well-designed health checks that will catch bugs for you and automatically roll back. Deployment for robotics is slightly different
而在边缘进行部署时，你需要确保无论何时进行软件更新，你都在本地拥有可用的且准备就绪的先前回滚。并且你拥有一个可以为你做到这一点的操作系统。我想苹果公司做得很好，如果有什么样的错误，你可以，或者假设你在更新过程中关闭了手机，它会恢复到功能状态。所以当你部署在边缘并准备好回滚和健康检查时，你确实必须考虑这些事情。所以是的，我想这说得通。然后把它们放在边缘
from deployment for cloud because cloud is always connected. You always know that there's going to be a network link. It's easy to roll back. You don't even have to have, let's say, rollback artifacts present at the edge in the cloud. I mean, you can just resend the latest artifacts or the previous artifacts that you wanted to roll back to.
并且能够回滚，而且你谈到了没有持续的通信。所以我很好奇，当机器人想要进行更新时，是否会发生某种协商，比如什么时候是做这件事的好时机？还是那是某种预先编程的东西？
Whereas when you're doing deployment at the edge, you need to ensure that whenever you're making a software update, you have the previous rollbacks locally available and ready to go. And you have an operating system that can do that for you. And Apple does this pretty well, I guess, where if there's some sort of bug that you can, or let's say you turn off your phone in the middle of update, it will revert back to a functional condition. So you do have to think about those kinds of things when you are deploying at the edge and having that rollback ready and health checks. So yeah, I guess that makes sense. And then having them on the edge
就像，哦，晚上插上充电器的时候。是的，不，这是一个有趣的问题，对吧？我想，就像我提到的，健康检查。如果你没有网络链路，你怎么知道健康检查已经失效了？所以当然你也许可以，你知道，拥有一个模式，比如说在无人机中，也许它有一个生命周期。
and being able to roll back, and you were talking about not having constant communication. So I'm curious, is there some sort of negotiation that occurs about when a robot wants to take an update, like when it's a good time to do it? Or is that something that's sort of just pre-programmed?
让我们考虑一个无人机交付系统的例子，无人机，比如说，在无人机中，也许它有一个生命周期。让我们考虑一个无人机交付系统的例子，无人机，比如说，飞来飞去，进行交付，并在一天结束时返回基地。所以你也许可以围绕那些频繁的着陆来规划你的软件更新过程，在那里相对更安全，或者是一个更好的交付更新的时间。但与此同时，当你构建回滚机制时，它们不一定只能存在于云端。
It's like, oh, at night when it's plugged into the charger. Yeah, no, that's an interesting question, right? I guess, like I mentioned, health checks. And if you don't have the network link, how do you know that health checks are gone off? So it's certainly you could maybe, you know, have a pattern where, let's say in a drone, maybe it has a life cycle.
你确实必须让其中一些存在于边缘本身。而且机器人必须能够自己弄清楚它的最新软件是否对它有效。而且它不能依赖云来进行该更新。然后我想，你知道，我们一直在谈论确保事情正常工作，你提到了模拟。
Let's say, let's consider the example of a drone delivery system where the drones, let's say, in a drone, maybe it has a lifecycle. Let's say, let's consider the example of a drone delivery system where the drones, let's say, fly around, make the deliveries and return to base at the end of the day. So you could maybe have your software update process kind of planned around those frequent landings where it's relatively safer or a better time to deliver the updates. But at the same time, when you build the rollback mechanisms, they cannot necessarily only live at the cloud.
我的意思是，我认为人们考虑为他们的软件编写单元测试，也许还有集成测试，但机器人系统的模拟与人们习惯的有什么不同？是的，绝对是这样。所以我认为，我想，如果你正在构建云应用程序或数据库系统，你不一定需要在你的，假设你有异构的机器人中需要模拟组件。假设你有不同版本的机器人，不同版本的传感器。也许
You do have to have some of those living on the edge itself. And like the robot has to be able to figure out on its own whether its latest software is working for it or not. And it cannot rely on the cloud for that update. And then I guess, you know, we've been talking about making sure things work, and you mentioned simulation.
它们有不同的硬件组件。所以仅仅那几个变量就导致了，比如说，配置上的组合爆炸。所以你的软件是在异构的环境中运行，在更多样化的环境中。仅仅那一部分本身就增加了测试和部署软件的复杂性。所以你确实需要在云中模拟你的硬件设备，这增加了额外的可测试性层。所以在部署之前，你有一些信心水平，而不是没有信心水平。是的。关于这一点的一个问题真的，真的很有趣。使用模拟的整个想法
I mean, I think people think about writing unit tests and maybe integration tests for their software, but how is, like, simulation for sort of robot systems different than maybe what people are used to? Yeah, absolutely. So I would say, I guess, if you're building a cloud application or database system, you don't necessarily need a simulation component in your, say, you have a heterogeneity of robots. Let's say you have different versions of robots, different versions of sensors. Maybe
作为测试，我想到的就像当你编写单元测试时，你知道，它是，假设你正在测试加法运算符。所以你做二加四，然后你验证它是六，对吧？所以验证，就像，你知道正确答案应该是什么。即使它更复杂，你也可以很容易地估计它，或者你可以有一些常识推理。但如果它是模拟，就像，你知道，驾驶这架无人机或驾驶这辆自动驾驶汽车在街上行驶。我的意思是，显然，有极端情况，你知道，你掉下悬崖或类似的事情，但是，但在一般情况下，就像，你如何真正知道如果，测试通过了，你知道，就像保真度是什么，因为它是，它不是一个二进制的东西。就像，你如何知道
they have different hardware components. So just those few variables leads to, let's say, a combinatorial explosion in configurations. So your software is running in a heterogeneity of environment, in a much more diverse set of environments. And just that piece itself increases the complexity of testing and deploying your software. So you do need some notion of simulation or simulating your hardware devices in the cloud, which adds that extra layer of testability. So before you deploy, you have some level of confidence versus no level of confidence. Yeah. One question about this is really, really interesting. The whole idea of using simulation
测试的质量？而且你是在做某种自我监督的事情吗？就像如果我能预测接下来会发生什么，那么也许那就是成功。即使接下来发生的事情很糟糕。就像，你能带我们了解一下吗？我认为这太有趣了。不，绝对是这样。我认为你确实抓住了那种问题的复杂性，是的。所以至少我思考类似事情的模型是，我认为它更像 UI 测试，而不是单元测试或后端测试。原因就是你提到的，你有一个机器人，然后它必须做事情
as a test and what comes to my mind is like when you write a unit test, you know, it's, it's, let's say you're testing the addition operator. And so you do two plus four and then you verify that it's six, right? And so the verification, like, you know what the right answer should be. And even if it's something more complicated, you can estimate it pretty easily, or you can have like some common sense reasoning. But if it's a simulation, like, you know, fly this drone or drive this autonomous car down the street. I mean, obviously, there's extreme cases, you know, you fall off a cliff or something, but, but in general, like, how do you really know if, if the test passed, you know, like what the fidelity was of the, cause it's, it's not a binary thing. Like, how do you know
在环境中，它可能不是确定性的。所以你可能会做不同的事情，那可能是有效的。你如何验证这一点？所以它确实增加了测试的复杂性。当然，当你构建自动化测试系统时，要记住的关键点是脆弱性，测试有多脆弱。所以当我思考测试这些机器人系统时，至少我总是回到谷歌测试金字塔。我不确定你是否
the quality of the test? And are you doing some kind of like self-supervised thing? Like if I can predict what's going to happen next, then maybe that is success. Even if what happens next is bad. Like, can you walk us through that? I think it's so interesting. No, absolutely. I think you do hit the nail on the complexity of that kind of problem where, yeah. So at least my model for some thinking of something like this is I think of it a lot more like almost like UI testing and less like unit testing or backend testing. And the reason for this is like you mentioned, you have a robot and then it has to do stuff
熟悉那个概念。也许我可以简要地提到它是什么。是的，我从来没听说过。好的。是的。所以我想测试金字塔本质上是一个金字塔。它有三层。在底部是金字塔最厚的部分，是你的单元测试。这基本上意味着你希望你的大部分测试集中在单元测试上。金字塔的中心部分是他们所说的集成测试，在他们的定义中，它确实是调用集成测试，在他们的定义中，它确实是多个单元的集成。所以如果在一个程序中你有，比如说，两个函数，它们都以某种方式结合起来以实现某个目标，并且你在你的程序中端到端地测试它，那
in the environment and it may not be deterministic. So you may do different things and that might be valid. How do you verify that? So it really does increase the complexity of your tests. And certainly when you're building an automated testing system, key thing to keep in mind is flakiness and how flaky is the test. So when I think about testing these robotic systems, at least I always go back to the Google testing pyramid. I'm not sure you're
是一个集成测试。最后，有端到端测试，也就是对整个系统的测试。在 Web 应用程序中，这意味着测试数据库、UI 和你可能拥有的任何中间件，并测试整个工作流程。我想这里的关键部分是你希望你的大部分测试集中在底部，即单元测试集，你希望有更少的集成测试，
familiar with that concept. Maybe I can briefly mention what it is. Yeah, I've never heard of it. Okay. Yeah. So I guess the testing pyramid is essentially a pyramid. And it has like three layers. At the bottom is like the thickest part of the pyramid is sort of your unit tests. And that basically means that you want to have most of your tests concentrated unit tests. The center part of the pyramid is what they call integration tests, which in their definition, it really is integration of call integration tests, which in their definition, it really is integration of multiple units. So if in a program you have, let's say, two functions and they both are combined in a certain way to achieve some goal and you test that end-to-end within your program, that
并且你希望有最少的端到端测试。这里的核心推理或核心逻辑是端到端测试。这里的核心推理或核心逻辑是端到端测试是脆弱的。那里发生的事情更多。那里有更多的复杂性。仅仅思考测试金字塔甚至可以帮助你重构你的代码，使其在单元测试级别更具可测试性，而不一定非要依赖端到端测试。所以我认为这是一个非常强大的框架，当你思考你应该如何构建测试以及你应该如何甚至构建时，
is an integration test. And finally, there's end-to-end testing, which is the testing of the entire system. In a web application, that would mean testing the database, the UI, and whatever middleware you might have, and testing that whole workflow. And I guess the key part here is that you want to have most of your tests concentrated at the bottom, at the set of unit tests, and you want to have fewer integration tests,
比如说像模拟测试这样的东西。是的，如果这说得通的话。是的，这说得通。酷，谢谢你的解释。是的，我想这适用的方式，至少在我脑海中对于模拟来说，是我们有这些机器人可以做的行为。比如说你有一个无人机交付
and you want to have bare minimum end-to-end tests. And the main reasoning or main logic here is that end-to-end tests. And the main reasoning or main logic here is that end-to-end tests are flaky. There's a lot more going on. There's a lot more complexity going on there. And just thinking about the testing pyramid helps you even restructure your code so that it's more testable at the unit test level and does not necessarily have to rely on end-to-end testing. So I think it's a pretty powerful framework when you think about how should you structure a test and how should you even structure,
行程，并且你想要进行那个行程，并且你想要以自动化的方式验证其中的各个方面，你会专注于测试其中的最少部分。所以也许你测试系统的所有消息传递，或者你也许测试系统可能拥有的某些终端状态，但你可能会尝试，比如说，放松无人机交付的约束。也许它不一定测试它采取的确切路径。所以你可以也许只是说，
let's say something like a simulation test. Yeah, if that makes sense. Yeah, that makes sense. Cool, thanks for explaining that. Yeah, I guess the way that applies, at least in my head for simulation is that we have these behaviors that robots can do. Let's say like you have a drone delivery
好的，我们将测试开始状态和同步状态，并忽略中间的所有内容。而这导致了更多健壮的测试，这些测试不一定脆弱。不错。所以也，我想我好奇的事情之一是
trip and you want to make that trip and you want to verify aspects of that in an automated fashion, you would focus on testing the bare minimum of that. So maybe you test all the message passing of the system, or you maybe test some terminal states that the system might have, but you would probably sort of maybe try and like relax the constraint of the drone delivery. Maybe it doesn't necessarily test the exact path that it takes. So you can maybe just say,
模拟以及你怎么知道？所以如果你最终要在一个设备上，它有什么，你会称为什么，像执行器，电机，类似的东西？你最终会运行一个测试，试图看看，电机真的动了吗？是的，是的，这是一个好问题。我认为至少我目前对机器人技术的模型之一是，我们实际上发现机器人技术，执行器或机械工程实际上相当复杂。而且它在很长一段时间内已经被证明是有效的。而且通常情况是，就像那些，至少在我熟悉的应用程序领域，比如无人机，那些实际上在构建这些机器人时并不是最大的担忧
okay, we're going to test the beginning state and the sync state and ignore everything in the between. And that sort of like leads to a lot more robust tests that are not necessarily flaky. Nice. So also, I guess one of the things that I'm curious about is like
应用程序。所以大多数时候你实际上可以依靠机械组件相当可靠，主要是因为我们处于这条曲线上，你知道，我们一直在构建超级花哨的机械机器人。我的意思是，你可以看到波士顿动力公司的机器人。我的意思是，它们有这么多执行器。我甚至不知道，对吧？我的意思是，执行器的复杂性和功效以及，你知道，它是执行器的创新阶段，它们非常可靠。这就是原因之一
simulation and how do you know? So if you're ultimately going to be on some device, which has what do you what would you call like an actuator, a motor, something like that? Do you end up running a test where you try to see like, does the motor actually move? Yeah, yeah, that's a good question. I think at least one of my models for robotics these days is we actually find that the robotics, the actuators or the mechanical engineering that is actually quite sophisticated. And it has sort of been proven out over a long period of time. And it's often the fact that like those are, at least in the application domains I'm familiar with, like drones, those are actually like not the biggest concern when it comes to building these robotic
我个人对机器人软件平台感到兴奋，因为我认为如果你考虑工具或各种构建块，比如 Arduino，比如 NVIDIA Tegra，这些实际上非常新。所以我们处于，比如说，软件方面的 S 曲线的最早阶段。因此，这在某种程度上，至少在我个人的经验中，使我更加关注
applications. So most of the time you can actually rely on the mechanical components being fairly reliable, mostly because we're kind of in this curve where, you know, we have been building super fancy mechanical robotics. I mean, you can see the Boston Dynamics robots. I mean, they have so many actuators. I don't even know, right? I mean, the complexity of actuators and the efficacy and the, you know, it is very the innovation stage of actuators where they're really highly reliable. And that is one of the reasons
测试软件组件本身。并且只是说硬件人员做得非常出色。而且我完全信任硬件，而且很多，知道，做得非常出色。而且，你知道，我完全信任硬件。而且目前对软件的信任要少得多。你让我想起，你知道，起初就像，哦，你是什么意思你只是信任？但我认为如果你曾经，或者至少我遇到过几次，和非常新的程序员在一起，他们会做某事，然后他们会检查两次。所以就像在他们的代码中，他们会做，你知道，杰森之前指出的那样，就像一加一等于二，然后他们会写一个检查
I'm personally excited about robotic software platforms, because I think if you think about the tooling or the various building blocks, like Arduino, like NVIDIA Tegra, these are actually very new. So we are at, let's say, the earliest stages of the S-curve on the software side of things. Therefore, this has sort of, at least in my personal experience, made me focus a lot more
来说如果它等于二，然后在检查里面他们会再次写它，就像如果它等于二，然后你问他们，它会在这些之间改变吗？它怎么会改变？好吧，我不知道，对吧？就像，好吧，是的，但在某种程度上，如果你不能信任计算机不修改随机值，那么你的整个程序就没有意义。所以当你这样说电机时，是的，我的意思是，总有一条线。你最终信任 CPU 是可重复的，并且它运行的指令是可重复的，对吧？我们通常不测试那个。
on testing the software components itself. And just saying the hardware guys have done an awesome job. And I trust the hardware completely and a lot know, done an awesome job. And, you know, I trust the hardware completely. And a lot, lot less trust in the software at the moment. You remind me like, you know, at first it's like, oh, how do you, what do you mean you just trust? But I think it's funny if you ever, or at least I've run it across a couple of times with like really new programmers where they'll do something and then they'll check it twice. So like in their code, they'll do, you know, like Jason was twice so like in their code they'll do you know like jason was pointing out before like one plus one equals two and then they'll like write a check
在测试软件组件本身时。只是说硬件团队做得非常出色。我完全信任硬件，而且我知道他们做得非常出色。而且，你知道，我完全信任硬件。目前对软件的信任度要低得多。你让我想起，你知道，起初就像，哦，你怎么，你说的完全信任是什么意思？但我认为很有趣的是，如果你曾经，或者至少我遇到过几次，一些非常新的程序员，他们会做某事，然后检查两次。就像在他们的代码中，他们会做，你知道，就像杰森之前指出的那样，比如一加一等于二，然后他们会写一个检查
to say if it's equal to two and then inside the check they'll write it again like if it equals two and then you ask them like is it going to change between these like how would it change like well i don't know right and it's like, well, yes, but at some level, if you can't trust the computer to not modify random values, then your whole program doesn't make any sense. So when you say this about motors, yeah, I mean, there's always a line. You're ultimately trusting that the CPU is repeatable and the instructions it's running, right? We don't normally test that.
来判断它是否等于二，然后在检查内部他们会再次编写，比如如果它等于二，然后你问他们，它会在这些检查之间改变吗？它怎么会改变呢？好吧，我不知道，对吧？这就像，好吧，是的，但在某种程度上，如果你不能相信计算机不会随意修改数值，那么你的整个程序就毫无意义了。所以当你这样说电机时，是的，我的意思是，总有一条界限。你最终信任的是 CPU 是可重复的，并且它运行的指令是正确的，对吧？我们通常不会测试这些。
And so, yeah, there always is some line where you don't test below. Yeah, yeah. And certainly, I'm always is some line where you don't test below. Yeah, yeah. And certainly, I'm sure the CPU has hiccups, like it's not a there's no 100% system in the real world. There's no lines, no triangles, right? These geometric objects are ideal objects, like platonic ideals. So and there's no 100% working computing system, but it just works most of the time or sufficiently enough that we don't have to think about it. And I think, although like, to be honest, like a funny thing I did run into was they are actually on the ARM computing platform, the guarantees are much weaker. So if you're writing concurrent code and you're doing lock free concurrent concurrency, there's actually no guarantee in execution patterns. So it can actually maybe sometimes that trust breaks down even on the computing side.
所以，是的，总有一条界限是你不会去测试的。是的，是的。当然，我肯定CPU会有小故障，现实世界中不存在100%完美的系统。没有直线，没有三角形，对吧？这些几何对象是理想对象，就像柏拉图式的理想。所以，不存在100%正常工作的计算系统，但它在大多数时候都能工作，或者说足够好，以至于我们不必去考虑它。我认为，虽然说实话，我遇到的一个有趣的事情是，实际上在ARM计算平台上，保证要弱得多。所以如果你在编写并发代码并进行无锁并发处理，执行模式实际上没有任何保证。所以有时候，即使在计算层面，这种信任也会崩溃。
Yeah, I mean, all of the like out of order execution stuff that they had Intel that led to like the specter vulnerabilities and all of that. Yeah, it turns out none of us know what the CPU is doing or at least not that we thought it should. But cool, I wanna make sure we get a little bit of time to talk about,
是的，我的意思是，英特尔拥有的所有乱序执行之类的东西，导致了像Specter漏洞之类的所有问题。是的，事实证明我们谁都不知道CPU在做什么，或者至少不是我们认为它应该做的那样。但很酷，我想确保我们有一点时间来谈谈，
so we talked about most of the elements. I think there was a couple we left off, but I wanna to make sure we have a few minutes to talk about sort of like what comes next. So you were describing sort of having a platform where, you know, the robots data gets brought in, you know, somewhat you deal with this heterogeneity creating like, you know, I imagine you didn't really talk about this, but like databases where the data is stored and can be analyzed and sort of gone over, which leads to the ability to like refine behavior and improve things by doing traditional like big data analytics. But like beyond that, you know, I don't know, what is your thought? Like, I have some stuff, but I don't want to like
我们讨论了大部分要素。我想还有几个我们没提到，但我希望能有几分钟时间谈谈接下来会发生什么。你刚才描述了一种平台，你知道，机器人的数据被引入，你处理这种异构性，创造出，你知道，我想你没怎么提到这个，但比如存储数据并可以进行分析和回顾的数据库，这导致了通过进行传统的像大数据分析那样的方式来优化行为和改进事物的能力。但除此之外，你知道，我不知道，你怎么看？我有一些想法，但我不想
bias the conversation. So I guess I'll let you go first. Like, what do you think comes next? So like, there's more and more robots, you mentioned, like drone delivery, Boston Dynamics, like, cars, like, I think we are seeing more robots. Like, that's inevitable at this point. Like, what do you think comes next? Yeah, absolutely. I think it's an interesting question. When I think about sort of, let's say, technological progress in general, I'm often reminded of Isaac Newton's line on this, which is, if I have seen farther, it is by standing on the shoulder of giants. And similarly, I think we have technological progress when we stand on the shoulders of
引导对话。所以我猜我让你先说。你认为接下来会发生什么？比如，机器人越来越多了，你提到了无人机配送、波士顿动力、汽车，我认为我们确实看到了更多的机器人。这一点在目前看来是不可避免的。你认为接下来会发生什么？是的，绝对。我认为这是一个有趣的问题。当我思考一般的技术进步时，我经常想起艾萨克·牛顿的那句话，即如果我看得更远，那是因为我站在巨人的肩膀上。同样，我认为当我们站在巨人的肩膀上时，我们就会取得技术进步。
platforms. And certainly there's like, you can think of these in layers. So we have the Linux layer, we have the operating system layer, we have the networking layer, we have the hardware layer. And like we mentioned earlier about trust, like when we make progress, we trust each layer of the system incrementally. Similarly, so when we have these platforms, I think we are not quite there where we can say we have a mature set of robotics platforms on top of which we can
平台。当然，你可以把这些看作是分层的。我们有Linux层，我们有操作系统层，我们有网络层，我们有硬件层。就像我们之前提到的关于信任的问题，当我们取得进步时，我们会逐步信任系统的每一层。同样，当我们拥有这些平台时，我认为我们还没有达到可以说我们拥有成熟的机器人平台，可以在其上
easily build applications but if it did or once we do have some of these mature platforms which in which is very easy to build applications you have higher apis one of the things i've been fantasizing about is you have this you you just literally have a declarative behavior specification system and everything else is abstracted away from you. You don't have to think about the systems. You don't have to think about the deployment or the simulation. All of that is like somehow provided to you.
轻松构建应用程序的程度。但如果实现了，或者一旦我们拥有了一些成熟的平台，在这些平台上构建应用程序非常容易，你就有更高级的API。我一直在幻想的一件事是，你实际上拥有一个声明式的行为规范系统，其他一切都对你进行了抽象。你不必考虑系统。你不必考虑部署或模拟。所有这些都以某种方式提供给你。
If you have this kind of, let's say, platform, you can build higher order applications. You can do, I don't know, things like much better like fleet management for robots where they do actually, you know, optimize their paths. They do share tasks, collaborative autonomies. I would say one big area that gets enabled in this way, where if you have, let's say, a fleet of robots, they're not necessarily doing work independently or individually, but even collaboratively. So they are sharing data.
如果你有这种平台，你可以构建更高阶的应用程序。你可以做，我不知道，比如更好的机器人车队管理，它们确实优化了路径。它们分担任务，进行协作式自主。我想说，通过这种方式实现的一个大领域是，如果你有一个机器人车队，它们不一定独立或单独工作，而是协作工作。所以它们在共享数据。
Applications are like, you know, you can imagine a high order of applications. And, you know, this gets mentioned a lot, but I do think you can also start building really like powerful learning, learning systems that automatically, you know, learn behaviors. And once you have all that infrastructure in place, you can, you know, start doing some of the, the hopes we have for reinforcement learning and, and so forth. Yeah. I guess that's kind of like, that makes sense. Like moving up the abstraction ladder, let's call it and, and getting higher and higher order.
应用程序就像，你知道，你可以想象更高阶的应用程序。而且，你知道，这经常被提到，但我确实认为你也可以开始构建真正强大的学习系统，自动学习行为。一旦你有了所有这些基础设施，你就可以开始实现我们对强化学习等的一些期望。是的。我想这很有道理。就像沿着抽象阶梯向上走，让我们称之为获得越来越高的阶次。
So most people don't worry about programming and assembly anymore, or at least do it rarely, you know, we keep moving to higher levels. And then I think this thing you talked about reinforcement learning, I guess, is, is one of the things that I always think about, but it is probably in, well, Jason will probably chime in, but it feels like maybe in a little bit of a perpetual future where you see things like, was it open AI did a gym where it's like, oh, here's a bunch of video games with like standardized input. You were talking about simulation. I mean, if you have enough of a fidelity in your simulation, in theory, you can put agents in there, give them a motivation or not, and have them figure out like what it means to sort of move around in that world and how to optimize
所以大多数人不再担心汇编语言编程了，或者至少很少这样做，你知道，我们不断向更高的层次迈进。然后我认为你谈到的这个强化学习，我想，是我一直在思考的事情之一，但它可能处于，好吧，Jason可能会插话，但感觉它可能处于一个永恒的未来，你看到像OpenAI做的Gym，就像，哦，这是一堆带有标准化输入的视频游戏。你刚才谈到了模拟。我的意思是，如果你的模拟有足够的保真度，理论上，你可以把智能体放进去，给它们一个动机或者不给，让它们弄清楚在这个世界中移动意味着什么以及如何优化
themselves. And, you know, yeah, it's super like, yes, it gets very sci-fi, you know, people write about this, but hopefully they don't turn a Terminator on us. Yeah. Jason, what are your thoughts about that? Yeah. So, so actually I think robotics and reinforcement learning both have the same phenomena. And I don't know if maybe you gave me this, this soundbite, but feel free to take credit back for it. But people say, you know, it's called a robot until it works reliably, then it's called an appliance, right? So, so like your washing machine isn't a robot anymore. Your refrigerator isn't a robot anymore, but you know, at the time they were these mechanical, you know, aberrations, right? And they didn't work well.
它们自己。而且，你知道，是的，这非常像科幻小说，你知道，人们写这个，但希望它们不会变成终结者来对付我们。是的。Jason，你对此有什么看法？是的。所以，实际上我认为机器人技术和强化学习都有同样的现象。我不知道你是否给了我这个金句，但请随意收回功劳。但人们说，你知道，在它可靠工作之前它被称为机器人，一旦可靠了，它就被称为电器，对吧？所以，你的洗衣机不再是机器人了。你的冰箱不再是机器人了，但你知道，在当时它们是这些机械的怪异事物，对吧？而且它们工作得并不好。
And so that was the right time to call them robot. And I feel like reinforcement learning is actually falling through the same sort of situation where it's like it's reinforcement learning until it works reliably. Then it's like control it's reinforcement learning until it works reliably. Then it's like control theory, you know? And so, and so, yeah, I wonder if reinforcement learning is always going to be just the word for the thing that doesn't work yet and control theory and, and, you know, I don't know, bandits and all these other words will be used for all the things that are already established. But yeah, I mean, I think that both of them are, we're making tremendous progress in
所以那是称它们为机器人的正确时机。我觉得强化学习实际上也陷入了同样的境地，就像它在可靠工作之前是强化学习。然后它就像控制理论，你知道？所以，是的，我想知道强化学习是否永远只是那个还没能正常工作的东西的代名词，而控制理论、强盗算法和所有这些其他词汇将被用于所有已经建立的东西。但是的，我的意思是，我认为这两者，我们在两个领域都取得了巨大的进步，
both areas and robotics and RL. And I don't know if we'll see killer robots, because I think that the whole human values is we're still really far behind on that. But yeah, I think that, you know, getting a robot to like, you know, climb the stairs of, you know, 90% of houses in the country, like that would be really powerful. Or even just fold the laundry of 90% of articles of clothes would be amazing. And yeah, I wonder how far we are away from that. I mean, as someone who has no background in robotics, I can't tell if we're a year away from that or two decades away. Yeah, yeah, I think there's a there's a lot there, I would say. And I I love that you mentioned robotics as a pejorative term almost, where you don't want robots, you want like stuff that works, which is pretty funny, I guess. And I think there's some truth to that. My theory on this is that it's kind of like, I think people both overestimate and underestimate scale at the same time. So on the one hand, people believe that,
机器人技术和强化学习。我不知道我们是否会看到杀手机器人，因为我认为在整个人类价值观方面，我们仍然落后很多。但是的，我认为，让一个机器人能够爬上全国90%房子的楼梯，那将是非常强大的。或者仅仅是折叠90%的衣物也会很棒。是的，我想知道我们离那还有多远。我的意思是，作为一个在机器人技术方面没有背景的人，我无法判断我们离那还有一年还是二十年。是的，是的，我认为那里有很多东西，我想说。我喜欢你把机器人技术作为一个贬义词，你不想拥有机器人，你想要的是能工作的东西，这很有趣，我想。我认为这其中有一些道理。我对此的理论是，这有点像，我认为人们同时高估和低估了规模。一方面，人们相信，
you know, if you have big data, you can predict everything, you can know everything, you can know more about you, that the AI can know more about you than you know about yourself. So there's certainly that belief. But on the other hand, people underestimate the power of scale and the sense that there's something that does really change. There's a step function change that does happen once you do have that scale. And at least my theory of what has happened in machine learning was that initially it was kind of a toy and, you know, neural networks were kind of a joke. But then you did have maturity of systems. You know, Google had these really mature big data systems.
你知道，如果你有大数据，你可以预测一切，你可以知道一切，你可以比你自己更了解你自己，AI可以比你更了解你。所以肯定有这种信念。但另一方面，人们低估了规模的力量，即一旦你拥有了那种规模，确实会发生一些变化。确实会发生阶跃函数式的变化。至少我对机器学习中发生的事情的理论是，最初它有点像玩具，你知道，神经网络有点像个笑话。但后来你确实有了系统的成熟。你知道，谷歌拥有这些非常成熟的大数据系统。
Then it did start working. You know, it does really work for recommendation and search and so forth. But of course, with pretty hard limits at the same time. So my view on this is, again, going back to the software platforms, like once we have these robotic software platforms established and sort of permeating the world, that's when you get the higher order learning systems. And that's when they stop being robots and being, you know, things that work. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense.
然后它确实开始工作了。你知道，它在推荐、搜索等方面确实非常有效。但当然，同时也有相当严格的限制。所以我的观点是，再次回到软件平台，一旦我们建立了这些机器人软件平台并渗透到世界中，那时你就会得到更高阶的学习系统。那时它们就不再是机器人，而是能工作的东西了。是的，这非常有道理。
Yeah, Abe, thanks so much. I mean, this has been an awesome interview. So I know you have a website. We'll put it in the show notes and your Twitter handle. Is there any other thing you want to sort of like talk about or tell people to do or visit or read
是的，Abe，非常感谢。我的意思是，这是一次很棒的采访。我知道你有一个网站。我们会把它放在节目说明和你的Twitter账号里。还有什么你想谈谈的，或者告诉人们去做、去访问或去阅读的吗？
or, you know, anything you want to kind of say? No, I think that that sounds like a great, great spot to stop. So yeah, I do want to thank you for having me on the show. It's been a really awesome experience. All right. I want to thank everyone for, I guess, tuning in. That's outdated. For downloading or streaming the podcast. I think Abhay for, you know, coming on and talking to us about robotics platforms. Thank you to all our Patreons who help make all this possible. If you would like to become a Patreon, you can visit patreon.com slash programmingthrowdown.
或者，你知道，任何你想说的话？不，我认为这听起来是一个非常好的结束点。所以是的，我确实要感谢你邀请我参加节目。这是一次非常棒的经历。好的。我要感谢大家，我猜，收听节目。那已经过时了。感谢下载或流媒体收听播客。我感谢Abhay来和我们谈论机器人平台。感谢我们所有的Patreon支持者，他们帮助使这一切成为可能。如果你想成为Patreon支持者，你可以访问patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。
And we have so many great people writing in to us, telling us stuff and helping us out. And there's been a lot of enthusiasm for the sort of more frequent podcasts. So I hope all of you are staying safe and healthy and we'll see you next time. See you later. Music by Eric Barndoelen. music by eric barnwell programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们有这么多很棒的人写信给我们，告诉我们一些事情并帮助我们。大家对这种更频繁的播客表现出了极大的热情。所以我希望你们所有人都保持安全和健康，我们下次再见。再见。音乐由Eric Barndoelen创作。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品以进行重混、改编，但你必须向Patrick和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。